alors on poursuit la conversation avec
Charles Côté notre collaborateurs
criminalisme bonjour Charles alors
qu'est-ce que ça envoie comme message ce
jugement là de la cour d'appel
aujourd'hui
le message pour les criminalistes n'est
pas exceptionnel en soi la gravité des
gestes commis par Simon haul a été
soulevé à plusieurs reprises dans
d'autres décisions je parle pas des
faits précis de la faire mais des
fraises des frais semblables dans
plusieurs autres décisions allant
jusqu'à la Cour suprême alors on sait
très bien la gravité des gestes commis
ont un impact sur la victime ce que la
Cour d'appel rappelle parce que c'est
pas rien de nouveau c'est que on doit
tenir compte beaucoup plus de l'impact
sur les victimes et sur leur vie privée
et ça c'est quelque chose que la Cour a
reproché au juge de premier instance
d'avoir évacué dans de son analyse
l'impact que l'ensemble des gestes
commis et comme collègues de la
poursuite en effet mention
l'acharnement de Simon rould dans la
prise des photographies à deux reprises
dans deux séquences distinctes alors ça
c'était un facteur aggravant qui était
éliminé de l'analyse du juge de premier
instant et c'est un peu ce que la Cour
d'appel dit prenez en compte tous les
éléments pas seulement ceux qui font
votre affaire alors c'est évident que
comme plaideur on va mettre beaucoup
d'emphase sur ce qui fait ce qui relie
notre cause mais la Cour son travail
justement c'est de balancer les intérêts
de 1 versus les intérêts de l'autre pour
en arriver à une décision juste en
fonction du droit bon on imagine qu'il y
a pas beaucoup d'avocats de la défense
qui vont être tentés de plaider la même
chose évidemment vous allez me dire que
tous les dossiers sont différents là
mais ça envoie quand même un signal
c'est évident que on va devoir porter
une plus grande attention sur l'impact
sur les victimes et on devoir on va
devoir naturellement faire attention
dans la façon qu'on va s'adresser ou
adresser ses crimes là devant la Cour
parce que les juges naturellement vont
nous rappeler l'importance de l'impact
sur les victimes je vois mal un avocat
aujourd'hui plaider pour une absolue
dans un dossier qui se rapproche parce
que avec ce jugement là ça disons que ça
envoie un message oui est-ce que vous
pensez j'ai posé la question à mettre
vous voulez mais je vous la pose aussi
que l'espèce de fureur peut être
populaire ça peut avoir influencé pas au
point où les juges ont changé d'idées
mais c'est vrai que c'est l'air du temps
aussi et quand et ça ça fait énormément
de bruit l'été dernier mais il faut
comprendre que le droit criminel est un
droit qui évolue constamment c'est un
gros un droit qui c'est ce qui fait la
beauté du droit criminel c'est qu'il va
s'ajuster
en fonction des nouvelles mœurs de
société et dans ce cas-ci et on le voit
depuis plusieurs années il y a
énormément d'évolution par rapport à
notre compréhension de l'impact des
crimes à teneurs sexuelles sur les
victimes et la cour nous le rappelle
constamment qu'il faut de plus en plus
en tenir compte lorsque on doit évaluer
justement le la sentence a imposer à un
accusé alors et ici c'est un peu ce qui
reprochait au juge de première instance
c'est d'avoir fait fi de plusieurs
facteurs dont entre autres la plupart
des facteurs qui concernaient le
voyeurisme qui qu'ils ont considéré
comme état très agréable effectivement
bon on sait dans le jugement c'est écrit
à la dernière page que l'accusé doit se
rendre aux autorités carcérales au plus
tard lundi mais il pourrait quand même
se tourner vers la Cour suprême mais
s'il fait un appel et là je m'appelle à
la course suprême il devra quand même
dégrader la permission d'être maintenu
en liberté ou de retrouver sa liberté
devant la cour d'appel et ça c'est toute
un processus nouveau de révision et de
remise en liberté ils vont tenir compte
de la force de ces arguments en appel
pour décider si effectivement il peut
être mis en liberté ou non alors
théoriquement il a toujours été en
liberté il a et on pourrait certainement
si le respecter tout le temps ces
conditions parce qu'il y a notre dossier
c'est justement
alors ça va paiser dans la balance je
veux pas vous coincer mais si vous aviez
à étudier l'affaire est-ce que un motif
d'appel là-dedans où vous serez seriez
tenté de demander à la Cour suprême
j'ai lu la décision à quelques reprises
cet après-midi
c'est une décision qui est bien écrite
qui est bien motivée elle est claire
elle est concise je n'y vois pas de
principe d'appel ou de motif bon on
verra bien tout ça merci infiniment
Charles Côté ça m'a fait plaisir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI